[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about what
we want
today we have a real live girl here
you look familiar you guys [ __ ] up
you've never called me a girl
like you've never called me a girl i
caught you i called you a [ __ ] before
yeah yeah
nice is that only for girls score
there's a lot of guys i've called you a
girl with a big ass dick
yeah i like that i'll take it happy to
be here before you did have a dick you
probably have a long one a really thick
one
like this i appreciate that i think geo
would be uh one of these schlongers oh
damn she's packing it on the floor
that's a big one
i'm a steve yeah low-key not true
hyperbole i'm probably you can't use
words i keep telling you what hyperbole
you say hyperverbally hyperbole yeah
hyperbolic hyperbolic hyperbolic chamber
what's the difference between a
hyperbolic and a hyperbole
well hyperbole probably doesn't happen
that's why we have a girl here she can
help us yeah what's a hyperbole
i don't know i just have a big dick yeah
why do you have so many bagels
um i just ran out the door because we
had a really busy morning today
but did you come here from vegas like
this morning no we arrived last night
but then
we went to train at barbell brigade um
and then from there we just [ __ ]
rushed over here and i didn't get to eat
any food so i got the bagel where do you
stay where do you guys stay at now my
mom's house
very interesting yes
yeah so it's really cool nice it's very
interesting
because she lives in the hood hood so
just the conversations that i hear are
always
very weird like talk [ __ ] about my
family let's go no no like
like there was a car with the
emergencies on on the side
and then so she calls her mom and i was
like hey so there might be a stolen car
that was left here just let you know
just very nonchalant stuff or like or
i'm like hey mama i think i'm gonna go
jogging and she's like okay don't get
shot
i'm like thank you i think i think
that's just good advice though when you
go
right yeah anywhere i mean you know
that's not normal stuff if you live in
like monterey park or something i think
your parts running around he's like oh
gunshot
park is so [ __ ] elevated my bad
but where you live or where your mom
lives it's a lot of dangerous things
going on there is there is but that's la
though like you drive 10 minutes and all
of a sudden there's like gunshots yeah
and then somebody jacks too yeah for
sure you can even go to beverly hills
and it's so [ __ ] kind of sketchy
sometimes yeah if you go around a
certain corner you're like what the [ __ ]
happened this is crazy do you have that
in vegas that's
true okay bro don't set me up
from a mile away why do you talk so much
[ __ ] about california i [ __ ] love
canada you wanna talk [ __ ] about
california yeah you see pretty
defensively
ever since he moved you can't wait to
talk [ __ ] i can't wait to talk [ __ ] on
kelly i [ __ ] hate caleb
dude i [ __ ] hate what are your
stripes go oh dude just what we pay
nobody everybody's priced out of the
housing market everybody is like it's
crazy
that's why you gotta buy luna and make
money
so then you can stake that [ __ ] baby and
then
you can stay in california shield it
away from all other things and you can't
worry you don't have to worry about
money that's the hope is that we get to
build an elysium in california
elysium god what is that it's a [ __ ]
movie
it's a movie that wasn't even that good
of a i don't know
i thought it was another crypto yeah i
was like what the [ __ ] i was like what
coin is that again why did you say
animal house
like two words i understand elysium
elysium is different
yeah it's not an asylum it's where all
the rich people build this like super
sick place and then they're like hey
basically
[ __ ] everybody down there like a green
house it's kind of how our economy is
yeah exclusively is it like a bubble
like a dome bubble a it's an actual
thing it's like a space station
it's a matt damon movie guys yeah yeah
which one
it's well there's a lot of them we
bought a zoo
no we bought a zoo it's a great [ __ ]
movie underrated bro
he's in that yeah he's the star matt
damon face of it he's on the podcast and
then the [ __ ] we bought a zoo
he bought the zoo matt damon bought the
zoo well no we we bought this
oh yeah that's right so him and his wife
i think this is this is a good movie
no [ __ ] no i don't think so i don't i've
never seen it though maybe it's gray
oh but with the atrium the atrium
atrium that's a good ring to it yeah are
we talking about crypto now or what are
you talking about
the word ethereum atrium it does sound
similar
geo what do you like about vegas so much
um so someone described it as
frictionless living and it's
literally that minimal traffic um
everything's really clean
the mask situation is just kind of like
it's not in the middle it's either like
you have the option they allow the masks
to have a hole in it
whoa so that's pretty cool
yeah yeah you can literally do anything
uh
like you can go to the desert you can go
to the mountains you can um can
you go to the beach at the wind right by
a lake
yeah it's not that but it's actually a
beach to lake mead oh yeah okay
yeah it's like a few minutes from our
house
look i kind of like everything about it
dude i prefer all the fake [ __ ] too by
the way i'd rather go to a fake beach
any day of the week
you know what's funny so we've been
traveling to utah and literally all the
dope landscapes you're like oh that's
cars from downtown
oh yeah their cars are like disney does
such a good job of branding
like we'll be in like a munich germany
i'm like this
is disneyland that's
stupid it's not disney you're uncultured
swine
absolutely hundred percent their parents
when they start referencing disney [ __ ]
we don't say this is how disney copied
we're like they're copying
it's like you see the eiffel tower
you're like vegas
just like the shrimp in vegas they have
all of it together i like that
better one-stop shop right yeah there's
something for it i don't have to go so
far to
get all these places like italy and
[ __ ] paris
get it in one street get it in one
street it's just the [ __ ] tower
i do like that i do how does it feel to
be back
um good i'm trying to catch up with you
guys but it sounds like not much
that much has changed you haven't been
in l.a for like a whole month um it's
really humid now i
i in l.a realize yeah it's just dry over
there so that when you come back
yeah i feel like 100 it's just so dry
that when i
when i when i'm here my hair like just
feels [ __ ] huge right now i feel
sticky
like you're in hawaii like you're in
florida not that bad but it feels like
it's like a good day in florida really
is because it's just dry as [ __ ]
yeah no i know i was getting like bloody
noses my [ __ ] snot's all crusty
like my skin was really like that's
that's the negative part of vegas that
i just feel like i can't stay for a
while but you
bloody after a month it crushed up no
when you get the blade knows you look
yourself in the regular this is why i
peeled
taxes
stick it out bart stick it out it's all
like [ __ ] it
i save money on my taxes
[Laughter]
meanwhile your brain's boiling in your
head
you're like i love vegas it's [ __ ]
hot but i love it
i don't think we've been here back in a
month uh yeah right
here and a whole month yeah yeah and
there's scorpions you got to look out
for it i'm not used to that scorpion
yeah see that's no fair scorpions uh
well we saw one that was like this big
so we got like a so now it's a normal
theme there because it's the desert
cockroaches yeah that's their cockroach
so do you kill them or you just
catch them well luckily that's the only
one we saw so now i got the service
where like they
they do that pest control like we do it
every single month so like we're not
gonna get any i saw one in the garage so
i stomped on it i don't know if it's
live or not it's still there okay it's
just just okay you're not sure it's
alive no it's because you're not taika i
don't want him to go what's that and
then
yeah wait it's still there yeah he he
stomped on it but for tyka he left
do you even listen to what he says right
right right yeah and i take the picture
off and i just poke taiko
look at this and then he builds immunity
yeah and he won't be scared of it
right that's real parenting by the way
yeah i feel like you get like
tooth floss wrap it around the scorpion
and tycho would give it a walk
oh that's tight that is fun how did you
come up with that
yeah walk in a pet scorpion gina do that
once with the beetle and we were all
really pretty disturbed
disturbed as the record yeah she had
like dental floss she tied it around a
beetle and she was walking it
she was like the beetle was trying to
fly away and she was like yeah i'm
walking the view
really yeah that's tight it was
thoroughly disturbing
why was it sad for the beetle no it was
just a weird
imagery to see it was like watching live
anime to me
yeah it was very odd today's video is
brought to you by
human health via modern nutrition
it's pretty cool because i've been on
this whole keto diet you know what i
mean
um i've been integrating some
intermittent fasting and
this has probably been the most
healthiest
and the most uh what's the word like
lightest
that i've been feeling in my whole
entire life you also said your ibs kind
of went away too right by eating
healthier
huge like i used to deal with problems
with diarrheas
all the time eating gas station food all
the time when you get to a certain
age you just can't eat i'm 37 right i
can't i can't eat
gas station burritos every single day no
you know i don't have that body no more
man
yeah so i started to do keto and
um when you're conscious about what
you're putting into your mouth you start
realizing
hmm you know there's a lot of sugar in
everything like in a savory burrito
there's sugar in there yeah like
everything you buy i don't know why
there's so much sugar right and that's
why savory snacks has sugar
exactly like chips yeah so i'm like all
right i need to get
rid of this belly and i'm trying to be
like fit for the rest of my life
so i'm like i got to do this now and so
big ups to human because they sent me a
bunch of bars
it's freaking delicious man and when i
want that fix they do
have items that kind of trick my mouth
into thinking that they're kind of sweet
but they're not
there's no carbs really and i got my own
fix
and i can stay healthy without going
overboard with the gas station food
yeah and like joe there's a lot of
people that are trying to clean up their
lifestyle choices
whether they're on keto or not and
that's what's dope about human because
they're a nutrition company
they're trying to take the guessing game
out of counting macros
whether you are running keto or if you
just want to reduce the amount of sugar
intake
and they got stuff like mct oil the
human keto food bars they got all kinds
of stuff so if you're trying to figure
out
and pick healthier lifestyle choices in
case you got ibs 2
or you just want to feel better about
yourself go to human.com that's hvmn.com
off the record for ten percent off your
first order
ten percent off your first order go to
hvmn.com
off the record oh guys i actually
found a four and a half star sizzlers
that we gotta go check out yeah it has
it has like 600 reviews what yeah what
did they do
different i know right i looked at the
pictures and they looked the food looks
decent
like i was like this is the childhood
sizzlers that i remember because i
remember
it was good quality or i don't know what
quality
[ __ ] i was an elementary school kid but
i loved i loved sizzling they had the
best dino nuggets right
really good [ __ ] buffet all that no i
just remember it being so dope right and
then people actually dressed up for it
or whatever yeah
and then it went to [ __ ] i remember i
remember going like at celebration time
so they have a dress code
like you win the spelling bee and you go
to sizzler it was a fine establishment
man
it was it was like going to [ __ ]
black angus or something
don't you think that we're also
uncultured swine as well maybe because
because when i was that age i used to
think
chuck e cheese was like gourmet buffet
pizza dude i haven't it's
so good it's [ __ ] good yeah
during the covet times they actually
reopened their pizza kitchen
and renamed it pasquales and if anyone's
actually ordered it online it's
that's actually chuck e cheese did you
order from pasquale's
yeah and it's actually good but then but
then
when i ordered it i knew it was chuck e
cheese so you're kind of like oh it's
chicken
but if you didn't know dude you would
totally think it's some gourmet is it
all mismatched
like you know how they went through that
you know the the drummer guy the the
chef
how do i figure out that yeah that's him
that's what's going on that's pasquale
that's him on the pizza bar no but she's
saying is it mismatched like where are
the pizza slices
that was the controversy they had like
the leftover pizza
they hit it really well oh they poor
they wouldn't be leftovers because it's
coveted
oh true oh yeah those are that's true
because some of the slices will be like
this thin
and i'm like what the [ __ ] dude or
there's pepperoni on a vegetarian pizza
and they're like how does this happen
it's a nice walk card i just don't
remember i would think all that's cool
when i was a kid you know
like i'd be like oh cool they're
different sizes oh cool the pepperoni's
over here
i used to love the uh the square pizzas
me too because then the ones in the
middle don't even have crust
you just grab one of these guys you
don't want the crust i didn't like crust
as a kid
what i didn't like crust either i don't
like crust even now
crust i like it now but i don't like the
chocolate the garlic dip okay
but otherwise you could hate on crust
it's [ __ ] dry it's bread tell me why
you eat bread you eat i don't like bread
i don't actually don't like
that that makes sense i love bread when
you go to italian restaurant and they
got that
soft warm bread with the pesto
yeah he gets angry at the chef only
casey could hate on bread man
i would hate on bread you got throw a
lot of butter on bread for me to like it
i had no idea wait what about like a
croissant or like
delicious oh croissant's great oh so
it's different because it's buttery
what about like bread like bread like
when it's not good it has to be
exceptional what about the [ __ ]
cheesecake chocolate [ __ ] bread
oh goddamn the brown bread that's soft
and moist you're talking about
just regular like rolls and breads
what about freshly baked it's pretty
good so it has to be good quality bread
that's
good quality but like the quality the
quality of bread goes down really fast
it does like the moment comes out the
oven it goes down so fast and i'm just
like i can't handle
stale bread damn you are booze that's a
hot take bro
not liking bread is a hot take i i also
wanted to debate with these guys i was
like i don't like sandwiches either
sandwiches are boring well if you don't
like you don't like bread you're not
gonna like sandwiches
that's the a to the z dude
you decided you don't like all
sandwiches there's not one sandwich you
like i would never choose american
sandwich yeah uh specifically the
bunnies are pretty good
but i would never i would never go out
of my way to be like
let's go get a sandwich for lunch or for
dinner you know like
i'm gonna i'm gonna go get [ __ ] food
like real food like give me a steak or
like you know if i could choose
i would never choose a sandwich you
could have a steak sandwich
no not the same not not the same because
it's thinned out steak i like
i like the chunk of meat that you got to
chew on you know like when it's like
thinned out it's just like you don't
really taste the
you taste you're tasting bread more
you're tasting go get roast beef
sandwich out of deli dude i promise you
they give you so much meat you're like
this looks like it was just
made like in the back from a cow
slaughtered the [ __ ] oh yeah
get give it give it to me like that
never crave a reuben yeah
good cuban sandwich yeah a nice little
cumin
dude i'm getting hungry what's your
favorite sandwich dude reuben
no so like i'm kind of like you it's
like anything with two breads
[Laughter]
and another bread like you like where
it's like if i could just get meat or
whatever
that's for sure my go-to right like if
you go to like brazilian barbecue
you don't go give me this pecania in two
pieces of
carbs i don't do that but i can also
enjoy a really good sandwich and if like
all the flavors kind of blend and
complement each other
like i like do i do like reuben because
it is like a smoked meat
and then on top they use like i don't
know what's that an island coleslaw like
that sauerkraut
or coleslaw russian dressing russian
whatever the [ __ ] is called
and then you got the uh the other bread
that has like rye [ __ ] sandwich
man over there this guy loves reuben's
bro yeah this guy loves
grapefruit
[ __ ] extra lettuce pickles that's
tight
it's so sick we just gotta get you the
right sandwich i think great about the
rice sandwich what about mexican torta
yeah let's see those are pretty good so
just that americans
those are i get what you're saying it's
like i'm the same way it's like if if
we're going out for lunch like i'll be
like yeah let's get sushi let's get
korean bar we'll get some
something or deconstructed sandwich that
i can construct it together you know
yeah
but then like like like if you go to uh
like that uh
uh like that barbecue spot and and well
most barbecue spots are like rudy's or
whatever
like they're like deconstructed
sandwiches basically like you have to
put it together right
but then um yeah like sandwiches it to
me it's like a to-go food
like when you're on slack
but the psychology behind it is like if
i had a choice
that wouldn't be my first choice this
cat's like i don't like sandwiches
that's like saying
i don't like ice cream i only like
vanilla yeah it's like
there's a lot of people like that though
yeah i know but that's what i'm saying
you do like some sandwiches let me ask
you this though and not to get political
get political
let's go there popeye's chicken sandwich
love it yes very good so you do like
sandwiches
no do you like burgers ooh is it a
sandwich
is it considered i don't think so
burgers are absolutely sandwiches guys i
think i think it's a sandwich i think
burgers are burgers
burgers are delicious what makes it a
difference burger not a sandwich
it's two bread with meat and [ __ ] in the
middle yeah how do you describe it
shares tomatoes and lettuce and
yeah how do you describe it i think
sandwich is made with
don't take cold meats because some of
them come hot no no i think i think
what messes with my mind is it's got to
be toast or it's got to be baguette or
like a roll or a croissant
and it can't be like a bun but
everything
burgers have all kinds of different like
brioche and all this [ __ ] what about a
sloppy joe what is it
you put like a chicken in it then it's a
chicken sandwich maybe like a popeye's
chicken sandwich i'll give it it's not a
chicken burger what if you put a burger
patty
in two slices of bread like a melt a
patty milk like a patty milk yeah
sandwich not a burger so it's the
combination
of uh uh well cause it's a toast right
it probably is a sandwich it can't help
you but if my heart
says no they are they became a class of
its own
like i think it probably morphed out of
a sandwich
and then and then it became its own
thing you know
like like a truck is an automobile i
would say it's an automobile
but it's but it became a class of its
own it's [ __ ] [ __ ] real joe
that's what it is okay i'm sorry i'm
actually surprised at how intense that
explanation got it doesn't make sense
though it's political
it doesn't it's political dude it turns
famously it makes a lot of sense look
a sandwich would be an automobile right
same thing and then a burger would be a
truck it's a subset
but a truck is an automobile it is it is
but when you look at it when you think
automobile you think
car you don't think truck you think car
depends on the context of the
conversation if we're talking in work
terms and we're like on the job site but
who says
yo bring that automobile here you say
bring that truck here who says
automobile by the way and i'm not saying
it's not the same thing
but that's that's what it's a class of
its own but if someone goes
if someone goes anyone i'm in the mood
for a sandwich i can go for a burger
and then i think it's different and it
usually means something completely
different
when someone asks me you want a sandwich
i go i thinking
blt turkey club baguette true the boring
one i'm not thinking a hamburger
sandwich my mind goes to baguette
sandwiches
is a lox bagel a sandwich then it's an
open face
open face down get out of here bro come
on dude like what the [ __ ]
face this guy i thought you were hyping
me up
now you're bringing me down well it's
also that's what happens on that side a
lot
well it's also just they have your back
and then leave you hanging when i when i
don't agree i just don't agree
i think i'm i'm a pro segregationist
because like
when i think of that i think breakfast
sandwich which is
its own thing it might be a toast you
know what that is that's a toast bro
oh yeah a tote like avocado avocado
toast
is that a sandwich come on get your
bagel sandwiches out of my sandwiches
open face that's not it's a breakfast
sandwich do you want to know what my
version of a sandwich is wait i thought
you were looking at the definition of
he was right it can't help me they can't
help me so we don't know if burgers are
sandwiches officially
it's up to us it's weird they're all
they're all sandwiches
i just don't like that it is okay so my
version of a sandwich
and i know i'm gonna break some hearts
in this group uh but it's thai food
that's my version of a [ __ ] sandwich
would you explain this explain it i just
don't ever go like i just don't think
it's a full-on meal oh i see it
like my my thoughts on sandwiches what
you think about
yes what
that's an awesome thing no it doesn't
feel like how is it not a full meal
um i just feel like like one i'm never
craving it i'm never like oh okay
fair enough go get thai food and then
once then
the rare occasion when i do eat it i'm
like
i don't feel like i eat [ __ ] so i'm like
forget it i'm just gonna get over it if
you eat your entire pad thai
you don't you don't get full off of a
pad not really like an entire order like
it just gets digested
really [ __ ] quick did you just
reviewed tim's parents cooking just
they now have that restaurant anymore so
no
no i didn't i only got to taste it when
we were filming and that's completely
different
and it wasn't a meal because it was cold
now it was not a meal it was not a
[ __ ] meal
i will die on this [ __ ] mountain it
was a it was a snack
when you stuff your face with pad thai
you don't get full don't feel satisfied
i don't feel that
you know what i'm talking about i don't
know how to i don't know how to explain
that
i guess we all have that yeah right we
all have a food where we're like
that's like me with salad it's lukewarm
i can i can stuff myself with any salad
and it doesn't
feel like i'm doesn't feel like i busted
my culinary nuts
yeah you gotta bust that knife
nothing competes with mexican food
though bro so i get it if you come from
that like and that's like what you're
used to
you're never going to get close you
think
thai food isn't hearty enough for you
party yeah
i think it's what we eat with thai food
yeah too though because i started eating
different things
with when i went to go eat thai food
with southeast asian friends
they order different like what like i
don't we never get like pad thai and
[ __ ] like that
it's like more meats and other stuff too
much carbs not enough protein
i like a curry though i like i like a
nice thai curry because i feel like thai
food in america is very different than
what they eat in thailand oh dude look
at indian food
yeah a little slept on thing by the way
people don't know about get the chicken
tikka masala
i had a friend who's a cook he uh he
showed me that one
[Music]
you